[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof but this is a very
special episode it's our 100th episode
of what's up rough
martin perhaps we should rephrase that
100 episodes of conspiracy theories
i think that would be a fitting title
actually yes
only trouble is what if they come true
right
yes and so that's why
we've decided we gonna do some recap of
what happened
over these 100 episodes yes
and um i think the viewers will enjoy it
it was
enjoyable to go through it again and uh
let's see how how
it goes let's pray let's pray
our heavenly father
we come here today and we want to thank
you
lord for all the miracles that you have
brought to
this ministry in the past
100 episodes thank you for
giving us the blessing of bringing these
to the world and we ask that you please
also bless this discussion today
and all the viewers in jesus name amen
amen
martin i think it would be appropriate
if you
would tell our viewers
about
what basically
transpired not in terms of the content
of the 100 episodes
but everything associated with it like
for example
making the information available how to
download it how to get it to other
people
etc perhaps you could inform them yes um
while i was going through the first
bunch of episodes i realized
it's
still as relevant today as it was when
we've made it
so
we've got this download server that
everybody probably knows off by now
we are in the process of upgrading the
the download server so
bear with us there is some
the
it's been flooded a little bit and then
sometimes the speed of the downloads or
it crashes or so but just bear with us
it will get better
and we've managed to procure another
server
where
the speed is many many times faster
and uh we're hoping that that will solve
the problem yes because like you've
mentioned this is an evangelistic tool
yes we want people to get and spread
this out as far and wide as possible and
i think we all know that time is running
out right
yes definitely and therefore we must
make it available in any form possible
so martin we've got all kinds of plans
to get the data out to the people in a
physical form
because we never know how long we will
have access to the airwaves right
correct and we want to do that also on
the basically the same basis
no profit just get it out
to the people
so whether that will be indeed dvd form
or whether it will be in a data stick
either way would be possible
so that the information can be spread
from person to person even if the
airwaves are cut off at some future date
yes
we also have
new telegram channels
there's for instance on afrikaans and
english channel at this stage and other
languages will follow and how this
channel works is it's like a server it's
got all our videos on there and then you
can share that link to other people and
they can join that channel and watch
through all of those videos the videos
are
quite small so it won't take a lot of
data
so that's also a new initiative and i'll
put the links in the description of this
video as well excellent so we have some
plans for the future definitely and
we'll keep everybody up to date but then
there's also a very special
thank you that we want to
give to our viewers
we've reached 100 000 subscribers well
that's wonderful so thank you very much
for all the support
and made
grow from strength to strength yes
because our only mission is
to get this message out
so that as many people can make
decisions
as is humanly possible yes and you've
mentioned earlier the time is short
correct and may god take it and multiply
it like
the leaves of autumn or like the loaves
and the fishes exactly well let's jump
right into it martin a hundred episodes
let's see
where we go
we spoke at some
time in the past about the abrahamic
family house
where the world is slowly moving in this
direction of uniting the great religions
in the world
you know what's interesting martin is
that many of the things that we spoke
about in the past in these episodes were
basically predictive that this or that
or the other would be a possible
scenario
of how things should unfold
so
in this episode we will have a flashback
yes we will go back to some of those
episodes and play short portions of what
was said
even
a year ago or more than a year ago so
this one comes from the 12th of march
and we can see how things have
progressed along this prophetic line yes
and
that is always one of the criteria that
one has to you know
watch
is that which is being said is it a
reality is it a figment of the
imagination or is it really unfolding
yes and i would encourage the viewers to
trick your
mind and go back to this date
and then realize what happened there
on 12th of march 2020
we didn't sit in the world that we sit
today no there was no global pandemic at
that stage it was just
centralized in china at that stage so
that's the type of thing you have to do
when viewing this and we'll keep on
reminding you because a lot of the
things that we said like you said
earlier
was
we were labeled conspiracy theorists yes
and this will never happen but in actual
fact it then happened to be that the
world actually experienced exactly that
so here is a video of what we said at
that time about the abrahamic house of
fraternity
they are building now a synagogue a
mosque and a church next to each other
next to each other right on the same
company right on the same complex they
built so and they've got a communal
garden in the middle
aha so the garden is the common ground
the common ground so they worship in
their own styles but they can together
under friendship
and fraternity now that is where i
believe all of this is heading
and in order to make it fit into a short
time frame
you have to have
magnitudes of calamities
so
the more the calamities increase the
more
the the pressure increase to introduce
these things
and because we're all interconnected and
all need to work together on these
issues eventually they will say
enough already
peace and good will to all men peace
peace we will live side by side we will
not attack each other anymore you can
believe what you believe as long as your
belief does not
interfere with this common good of
fraternity
so that was what we said in march 2020
and the question is have we had
calamities
i think everybody can agree that
it's really started to escalate
and even the magnitude of all the
calamities if you look at the latest the
tidal waves that we've had
the eruptions of
volcanoes under the oceans if we look at
the storms that we've had
the tornadoes the climate change of
course was brought into the fray and all
of these things are happening
and on this house of fraternity
they've even started to build
in different
areas in the world also they started in
berlin they're going to do in new york
and we said all of these things so there
is an escalation yes in terms of the
religions
working together
but
there
may be no proselytizing
correct that's what
pope francis
vehemently told correct but the bible
says go ye into all the world and preach
the gospel and make disciples
so we have a conflict
and
that conflict will not end until the
lord returned
so in 2022 seven stunning architectural
projects to open in the gulf
the abrahamic family house is one of the
landmark projects to be completed
sometime this year
and the project was unveiled in 2019
after the signing of the document on
human fraternity by pope francis
and the grand imam of al-asar ahmed
al-tayeb
so we've discussed all of this so these
things are
in the pipeline and developing very
rapidly
martin in the past when we talked about
these things we said
that it wouldn't stay with a pandemic it
would escalate
and there would be supply line problems
and we discussed
food crisis
and crises that would develop in the
world and people said this is just a
glitch on the horizon it will never
happen
but where are we standing right now
in
on the issue of food crisis
all right just to recap this is what we
said on the 12th of march 2020
and now
there is the coronavirus
interesting and i find this coronavirus
very fascinating
because number one it uh
exposes a weakness
an authoritarian
regime that is curtailing the virus by
isolating it yes
but by isolating it you are
stopping the movement of millions of
people
you're not only stopping the movement of
millions of people
you are stopping the movements of
millions and millions and millions of
dollars of merchandise
so this does not affect
people only it affects the entire
economy
it affects
imports
and the way in which the government in
its
in its stance is
treating the people is leading to
dissatisfaction yeah
and i'm wondering if this is
a
part of the agenda or not i don't want
to be
labeled the conspiracist although i
think it's a little bit late for that
but what if what is the the backlash the
economy has received the knock exports
have received or not
for example the farmers in all these
quarantined areas and in these cities
that have been closed
you have these massive chicken farms for
example
now they're sitting with all these
chickens
what are they going to do with them
they can't
export them because the trucks and the
trains that come and take these things
away are no longer allowed to do this so
the only thing they can do is to kill
them all yes so they're slaughtering
millions and millions and millions of
animals
without the means of creating an economy
which is sustainable in other words
they're saying there will be massive
food shortages
and because of the export market that
will
ripple over to the entire world
and what isn't that interesting that was
said in 2020
when there was
not even a hint of it at that particular
stage
so let us go to a cartoon
that comes out of fox news
and this is a very recent one it comes
right from the last few days so what
does it say here
it says build back better supermarket
and it seems like there's nothing on the
shelf martin
chips out of stock baked goods out of
stock canned goods out of stock covert
test kits out of stock
beer out of stock cereal out of stock
but the good news is
that joe biden with his
bbb pulled back better emblem on his
on his chest
and his teleprompter
and his
thoughtlessness
states the good news is that we have
shorter checkout lines
so it is a reality it has come to
fruition
we are now in
2022 and that was in 2020.
so was it a conspiracy theory or did it
actually become a fact
here is an article from january the 13th
kfc australia is running low on chicken
and mcdonald's japan is restricting
sales of french fries
so
this is across the board
and
we will experience this more and more i
think so too
yes and eventually you know the bible
says there will be famines
and we are heading towards famines now
what's very interesting martin is
that some countries like china
are hoarding food right yeah
and
some of these hordes of food comprise
more than half the world's food supply
so let's just look at some of those
interesting things if we're talking
possible
scenarios for the future
yeah this is now the time that everybody
must put on their thinking gaps and look
a little bit further into the future and
see how this thing is unfolding you know
that we said at that stage this is not a
glitch on the horizon
this is the end game
and there was so much opposition to
those statements we still get opposition
to it correct but
more and more people are realizing
that the world has thoroughly changed
this is a new game
we might be moving out of one crisis
into another form of crisis but the
crisis won't stop and there might be
small short lived
time of relative just to calm the nerves
and then the next way
let's look at this little
clip here it's an interesting one
have you been complaining about the
growing inflation have your monthly
expenses gone up
are you now paying more for your daily
essentials things like rice cooking oil
pulses and more if you are you're not
alone it's happening across the world in
india for instance inflation has jumped
in sri lanka there is a food shortage in
nepal inflation has touched a 19-month
high in bangladesh inflation is breaking
records in the month of november it
touched a five-year high and in pakistan
food inflation is crushing the poor
that this inflation will get worse
because of one country china china is
adding to global inflation how by
holding the world's grain how much more
than half of the global supply china is
hoarding more than half of the global
supply of food grains
how much food supply is beijing hoarding
let's give you some numbers estimates
say china has 69 of the world's maize
reserves 60 of the rice reserves and 51
percent of the wheat reserves the costco
group runs one of china's largest food
stock piling bases
it is in dalian in northeast china it's
a port it has 310 huge silos
they store beans and grains supplied
from within child and abroad from here
the port of dalian china distributes
food to the rest of the country you
could say the kafko group is critical
for china's food security but for the
rest of us
it's a threat
because this mass hoarding of food in
china is impacting the world
69 percent of the world's maize
is not a small amount
that is huge that is reminiscent of what
happened in egypt right
all the nations around were dependent
upon egypt exactly so we spoke about
that also in the past now what is very
interesting
is that everything is interconnected
many of the truckers for example
refuse to go along with certain
government mandates
and that will slow down the distribution
because some of these people just won't
distribute it anymore yeah so that's an
added added problem but there are other
problems so this is an article in
farming ahead
where cbh growers require compulsory jab
in order to be able to deliver
so some just won't deliver for example
so let's just think about that where can
this
go to and where are we heading
remember that
in many episodes we spoke about get out
of the cities
the cities are going to be
places that are very dangerous to live
in
and in the past we also
wrote about coastal areas
and how dangerous it will be to live in
coastal areas well the volcanic eruption
that we've just had
that devastated the islands of tonga
are just one of the examples of
what we might expect get out of the
cities
so let's have a look what we said on the
12th of march 2020
the cities
are a hotbed
of
everything that is evil
and
as it was in the days of noah so shall
it be at the coming of the son of man
and we have examples of what happened to
cities like sodom and gomorrah
and the bible says that the earth will
wear out like a garment and the
inhabitants will die like flies
and
it is so easy to quarantine someone in a
city
if you take the cities of the world you
just cut off the main routes and within
minutes
there is a lockdown
and you will not be able to buy and sell
and you will be controlled completely by
the government
now what is also fascinating they were
saying there wasn't much of a patrol
in these lockdowns now what do the
authorities do to enforce
such a lockdown are the authorities or
those responsible for enforcing it are
they immune to the virus
or does a
plastic jacket protect them from the
virus and no one else yeah so there are
a couple of things there which just do
not quite ring true
nevertheless
whether it is real
or perceived is irrelevant
what is the consequence
and do we see the biblical events
unfolding
and i believe we are
let's just move straight on to another
clip
where it had this interesting
introduction here's a statement from
last day events
when iniquity abounds in a nation
there is always to be heard some voice
giving warning and instruction
as the voice of lot was heard in sodom
yet lot could have preserved his family
from many evils had he not made his home
in this wicked polluted city
all that lot and his family did in sodom
could have been done by them even if
they had lived in a place some distance
away from the city
that's pretty good advice
now we've just had a
rather devastating week in terms of what
can happen in cities
and
let's just look at what this little
video shows us
[Music]
okay
but if you were not in the city
then this would not have hit you now
what if this starts happening on a large
scale
and what if the judgments of god
are coming to this world
because of the iniquity sometimes god
does these things or allows these things
so people can wake up right
now martin
what if this happens on a very large
scale
or
let's not be predictive but just
speculate
china in one city
is hoarding 50 percent approximately of
the world's food supply
what if we had a similar event and that
food supply was wiped down then in one
day
the 50 of the world's food supply
will be gone yeah
immediately you're in a famine now when
we look at that
explosion that we had in lebanon
there were silos standing there and they
were also full and they were destroyed
so
we could have a natural disaster or we
could have an unnatural disaster or we
could have a wall
and then
we would see things like this
and what would be the impact
now
there's a statement in the spirit of
prophecy which says that just before the
end war will rage i think we must talk
about
some of those issues in a future one
because i think it is time
that we not only looked at the news
we didn't not only look at the events as
they are unfolding as important as they
are
we have to start looking at the
spiritual implications yes
we have to start looking where must i
and where must you and where must
everyone else be in terms of their
relationship
with god in the time that we are living
in martin
we have just seen the beginning
it's going to escalate
and now's the time to have that anchor
what you've just been talking about all
right so we just spoke about all of
these calamities that they would
increase let's look at what's happening
right now
the nation of tonga was virtually cut
off from the rest of the world after a
massive volcanic blast crippled
communication lines in the pacific
island the explosion has also stalled
all emergency relief efforts as of now
it has been two days since the tonga
volcano exploded the eruption cloaked
tonga in a film of ash
it triggered a pacific wide tsunami and
release shock waves that wrapped around
the entire planet
but with phone lines still down and an
undersea internet cable cut the true
toll of the dual eruption tsunami
disaster is not yet known
the eruption was so powerful that it was
recorded around the world and heard as
far away as alaska it triggered giant
waves along the pacific coastlines from
japan to the united states
and what was also interesting is if the
people go and watch the video the fool
that one you'll see there's a top
scientist that was that's studying these
type of things for 40 years and he said
this is a total surprise they didn't
expect something like this to happen
nothing now there are a number of
conspiracies out there
that some of these natural disasters are
being aided by human manipulation now
whether that is so or whether that is
not so is actually irrelevant true the
outcome is what matters always
yes so
we have been told there will be
calamities by sea and on the land
and that there will be
a
total turmoil of nature
and that is exactly what we are seeing
whether it is man aided or not whether
it is harp technology whatever it is it
doesn't matter
the outcome remains the same
the other thing we spoke about is the
rapid advance in terms of human
enhancement technology
and how far have we moved
in this
in those hundred episodes
from
when we started talking about it to
where we are
today
now how far along the line are they
in terms of
interfering with your mind
so that they can actually
not only modify it
enhancements they call it
but actually regulate it now that's
interesting correct now when we look at
the conspiracy theories out there we
have to make a point conspiracy theories
they're saying this vaccine could
contain nanoparticles this is
interesting right yes and that these
nanoparticles would then
sort of create a grid
whereby they can actually control you
via certain radiation particularly 5g
comes to mind etc
that's the mindset up there now we're
not going along with that we're just
saying that's the way it is
but the world economic forum
web page clearly indicates
that they want to go that direction yes
human enhancement control of human
thinking
control of what you do yes how you do it
etc
just to go a little bit further here's
the
the neurolink project and this comes
from cold spring harbor laboratory and
integrated brain machine interface
platform with thousands of channels
and this is of course elon musk
and his neural link technology that he's
been talking about this is fascinating
stuff yes
very interesting here's an abstract from
this article brain machine interfaces
hold promise for the restoration of
sensory and motor function
and the treatment of neurological
disorders
could it affect the way you think
if someone
ultimately does get a neurolink
installed what will take place
it can interface basically anywhere
in anywhere in your brain um so it could
be something that
you know helps cure say uh eyesight like
give you
returns your eyesight even if you've
like lost your optic nerve type of thing
uh really yeah yeah absolutely hearing
let's see um
i mean pretty much anything that where
that it could in principle fix almost
anything that is wrong with the brain
so you know they were talking medical
issues and it sounds like a wonderful
wonderful thing
but what if there is another aspect
of controlling your reality
then we would be
moving into the realms of science
fiction right correct and we've spoken
about that
the meta verse and you you might
actually be living in a matrix
in an unrealistic world that is being
created for you
so this is now
jumping to our time this is now
2022. let's see where we are
i recently tested the oculus quest 2.
omar and i even held a meeting in meta's
horizon workrooms i personally felt the
experience was moderately fun solely
because of the novelty factor however
after playing around with it for several
minutes i began to feel more annoyed by
the bright screen immediately in front
of my eyes additionally i experienced
the motion sickness that elon goes on to
describe here
like you can do a video game on your
sort of computer console or whatever and
and and you can
you can be in a like a first person game
and and uh and move rapidly and not get
set motion sickness but if you try to do
that in a beat with vr goggles you get
motion sickness it's like weird so you
have to like teleport around with
it's okay
so
that doesn't it doesn't feel like like
that's the answer necessarily
into the brain so you don't have to have
the glasses there you go yeah a
neurolink long-term sophisticated neural
link
could um
put you fully fully in a virtual reality
thing
so martin we can change virtual
reality we can make you see things that
don't exist
and you will think that they are real
this is very interesting isn't it
interesting and
i hope it's also a little bit scary for
the people absolutely once you start
interfering
with reality
and you create a virtual reality
then you are taking
humanity away from the roots
because god placed us in a reality
he didn't place us in a matrix
even though satan would like the world
to believe that god put us in a matrix
he placed us into a reality
he placed us into a physical world he
placed us into a garden
but here we have a virtual reality if we
go back to some of those old movies
where
they showed what the future would be
like
then this virtual reality would play a
great part especially if the world is in
a pretty destructive phase
you can create a reality that is unreal
and that's what's happening the world is
deteriorating and life out there you
don't want to actually be part of
anymore yes so you create your own
reality
and you own nothing and are happy
is that a possibility it's a i think
that's how the planning works that's how
the planning works now as soon as you do
that and you remove reality
then you cannot base decisions on
reality you would have to
base them on a virtual reality which is
not a reality
so my question is will god permit this
if he does
if god permits it
then he is permitting people to make
decision on something that's not real
yeah and that cannot be comprehended i
cannot see that happening
so
we are in the time as it was in the days
of noah
where amalgamation
and probably technology like this was
being introduced and god said every
imagination of the heart is continuously
wicked
and he will have to
remove
this situation
entirely
and interesting they've time and again
said that
this meta verse that we were speaking
about
act they can unfortunately not control
the age restriction or something in
there you can't control what people will
be doing in there that's interesting
so they want to
start this neurolink implanting process
in human trials in this year 2022
and they're starting with aiming to help
paralyzed people
but that is just the beginning
then they move on to
the next phase if you take it like this
you start off to get everybody excited
about it
and then slowly from there on you start
implementing correct
now what if you can introduce
a computer linkage
by means of
let's say
injection
is that a possibility is there a lot of
speculation in the world regarding that
issue
i've seen an article where google
and i don't can't remember the other one
are creating these
nano
bots
that will
that they want to use for medical
purposes but what else can they use it
for correct so it's in your body
and what is also interesting
there's now a lot of talk that this is
being introduced into the food supply
they're talking about you know graphene
oxide and the magnetism and all of these
issues now we actually did some
experiments ourselves
and we found in very common breakfast
foods we found these magnetic particles
so what are they doing there yeah and
when we looked at older packages they
weren't there but they are there in some
of the modern ones very strange things
happening
we've said all along
that
the world is not moving to a better
place no it is definitely on a downward
spiral and we will be talking about it
but no matter who's in charge
it will be going downward
then of course uh we also discussed this
interplay the sigeleian dialectic
between the left and the right
and you know people get so fired up
because
they
buy into
one
ideology either of the left or of the
right
and then demonize the other one but this
is one of satan's best strategies of
herding humanity into
a synthesis game
and sometimes it's hard to understand
how this is happening
and people might think well he's leaning
to the left or he's leaning to the right
but we've always maintained no we are
observers exactly we stand outside of
the scenario
and wherever the left is leading
wherever the right is leading if it is
associated with secret societies is if
it is associated with the papacy let's
call it by name
then you must know that there is an
agenda which
transcends
the
natural
world and we move into the spiritual
world they are interconnected you cannot
separate them
and we're going to see a fulfillment of
biblical prophecy whether it is
spearheaded by the left or whether it is
spearheaded by the right is irrelevant
so what did we say in june 2020
remember what prophecy says
that protestantism
would form an image to the beast
would give their power
unto the beast the kings of the world
will give their power unto the beast in
other words they will again
acknowledge papal supremacy and lend the
power of the state
in order to further the aims of the
papacy
and anybody who didn't go along with
that would be persecuted that's the
biblical narrative right
so you have this power on the one hand
which
elevates humanity
and you have the power on the other hand
which elevates christ
now which one are you going to obey
now are there any signs
that they are really working to joining
protestantism and catholicism in a
powerful union
that will again persecute god's people
in the end last night he held a bible in
front of saint john's episcopal church
just across the road from the white
house
today he'll visit the shrine of saint
john paul ii also in washington dc so
here you have
a protestant
and a catholic action
and trump signed an executive order
during the noon hour that the white
house described as prioritizing u.s
support for religious freedom worldwide
again we must qualify
that the papacy has declared that you
only have religious freedom in that it
serves the common good yes
a behind the scenes photo posted on
melania trump's instagram showed the
trumps kneeling in prayer inside the
shrine
would a protestant do that
would a protestant go and kneel in the
shrine or dedicated to a catholic saint
is this a signal
that a protestant president is willing
to bow down and bow the knee to catholic
principles
are we seeing a closing of the gap
i i think so
you have to be blind not to see this you
have to be blind right
definitely so is an image to the beast
beginning to form it's so
blatantly in front of our eyes
i don't understand why some people can
just not see this i don't understand it
either but we have very prominent people
saying there is no image to the beast
forming yes
and everywhere i look in the media i see
the image of the beast forming i don't
know do i have different glasses is
there something wrong with these maybe i
must clean it a little bit
now martin in those days when we spoke
about these things
donald trump was still the president of
the united states now we have another
president
and he has a left-leaning right
is he any less pro-papacy
no so this is a gillian dialectic
let's just hear again what donald trump
said in this
interview in 2020 in august
and if there was one message you wanted
to say to our viewers what would it be
right now well i think anybody having to
do with frankly religion but certainly
the catholic church you have to be with
president trump when it comes to
pro-life when it comes to all of the
things these people are going to take
all of your rights away including second
amendment because you know catholics
like their second amendment so i saved
the second amendment i have if i wasn't
here you wouldn't have a second
amendment and pro-life is your big thing
and
you won't be on that side of the issue i
guarantee if uh if the radical left
because you're going to take over
they're going to push him around like he
was nothing
now don't you find that fascinating
so here's the one who says the churches
should open
and the churches should side with his
philosophy particularly the roman
catholic church because their philosophy
is basically what he said his philosophy
now remember he's also a jesuit trend
i find this very interesting this is
exactly
what we see in the bible
that the mark of the beast will be
informed enforced enforced
by uh
church state
yes conglomerate now
let's say
that for argument's sake
this
philosophy is the one
that will turn out to be the one
wielding power
then there's a tremendous likelihood
that religious legislation
would come into play again to prevent
this chaos out there in the world isn't
that correct
here's an article trump campaign advisor
jenna ellis separation of church and
state is a liberal lie
now
martin that was the right speaking right
now the left joe biden is the second
catholic president of the united states
and he was greeted by pope francis
like a long-lost brother
and uh
everything that he stands for is
apparently the opposite of what the
previous regime stood for
and yet they're furthering the same
agenda is that hegelian dialectic at its
best at its best you cannot get it
better you've got people fighting each
other
but both parties actually have the same
goal exactly the same
this is unbelievable and we've been
saying this for a long long time and
it's unfolding before our eyes and yet
people think that they have chosen a
particular
side when in fact they're all on the
same bus and it's not over
because there's midterms coming
and then a re-election so we'll be
speaking about that but keep all of this
in mind with the discussing
wouldn't it be
absolutely hilarious if we had a re-run
of trump versus hillary well
don't put it off yet
on the 9th of october 2020
we had biden say his say as well right
so let's listen to that
and throughout my life in public service
i've been guided by the tenants of
catholic social doctrine that cuts
across all confessional faiths
and that sense of hope and possibility
reminds me of the first time i met pope
francis
in 2013
when i had the privilege of attending
his inauguration at the vatican
when i greeted him he said mr vice
president
you're always welcome here
i live in an amazing country
we all live an amazing country
where an irish catholic kid like me from
scranton pennsylvania would one day
befriend the jesuit pope
but that's who we are as a country where
anything is possible
it's fascinating to me that the biden
camp is
just as religiously orientated as the
other camp
you know we're always inclined to think
that the trump
campaign and the trump camp
is
closer to the king of the north
but in many respects the biden camp is
closer than the trump camp yeah
because he mentioned the catholic social
doctrine exactly
and the democratic party
has a manifesto and a vision which is
much closer to the catholic social
doctrine
than is the trump camp yes
so
the king of the north sets in both
and it doesn't really matter who wins
the ascendancy of the king of the north
philosophy
can just as well be in both parties
so
it doesn't matter at all who wins the
election
the the issue of prophecy will be
fulfilled
do you know how interesting this is
martin
so as we've said all along
it doesn't matter which horse you you
sit on it's going to go in a particular
direction
now
when you have a change from one to the
other
and we constantly have changed from one
to the other
then certain agendas can be
propagated
and when those agendas become
exceedingly unpopular you change horses
yes
got the same ideology but how much of
that horse still remains
all
the
things that the previous administration
put in place not everything has been
swung around by the current one so no
they get all these things in that they
want exactly
so if something is unpopular you just
switch horses yeah
and then they
they
carry on with that
narrative people
start okay let's go with it
until you get fed up with those and you
switch horses again this is a very
brilliant strategy
it's thesis antithesis synthesis
and
the spiral
is heading downwards
no matter which horse you're sitting on
yeah and the one is just blaming the
other one for it correct now some people
are saying that you know this president
is the most unpopular president
but just think back a few years to
george w bush jr
how popular was he
and yet he managed to push through all
his strategies then there was a change
of horses
and nothing changed nothing changed
so if we want to go into the philosophy
then we can jump to
the 15th of october 2020
and see what we said then this is quite
a while ago in 2022 already right
i want to point the viewers to this book
ecclesiastical megalomania
by john robbins it's a very fascinating
book and if you want to know more about
catholic social doctrine
and the economic principles of the roman
catholic church
and you would be wise to read this book
in 1948
the jesuit cavalier explained
roman catholic state political strategy
in la savelte catholica
it says the roman catholic church
convinced through its divine
prerogatives of being the only true
church
must demand the right of freedom for
herself
alone
because such a right can only be
possessed by truth never by error
in a state where the majority of the
people are catholic the church will
require
that legal existence be denied to error
and that if religious minorities
actively exist
they shall have only a de facto
existence without opportunity to spread
their beliefs sure
this is jesuit thinking
if you belong to some group that
believes the bible that believes that
jesus is the only way to salvation
that believes that the word of god is
the norm and standard for your life that
believes that the law of god in its
entirety all ten commandments is binding
you will be an anathma in the eyes of
this church
ain rand
was right when she wrote in 1967
the catholic church has never given up
the hope to re-establish the medieval
union of church and state
with a global state and a global
theocracy as its ultimate
goal
he writes further the roman church state
in the 20th century
however is an institution recovering
from a mortal
wound this is biblical language from an
economist
if and when it regains in full power and
authority it will impose a regime more
sinister than any the planet has
yet
seen
and if people still do not believe us
let us just go through a few papal
statements
to show that this encyclical is
absolutely in harmony with papal
thinking and has nothing to do with
fraternity and brotherly love it has to
do with megalomania
and power hunger
so martin
i have a question for you
when this power starts getting a grip on
humanity
then we will see an authoritarian regime
as we saw in the middle ages
i would just like to ask the viewers
what's happening in australia
yes what's happening in austria what's
happening in austria
what's happening in many many places all
over the world
even though
some of the pandemic issues are
seemingly going into decline
it doesn't matter the agenda will be
further and the church state
in especially
the second beast america
is clearly from both sides
going towards the goal going towards the
goal now here is an article in the new
york post from january 16 2022
ex-clinton advisor says there's a good
chance of
2024 hillary trump rematch
now whether this takes place or not as
we have seen from our discussion is
actually irrelevant right
it depends on which horse you want to
settle and if they want to sing this the
first verse all over again second verse
same as the first
then so be it if humanity is willing to
swallow such a ridiculous scenario then
let them
it seems as if humanity wants to be
duped
it it truly does right
so we don't have to read it all they
just said there's a very good chance
that this would take place and they're
actually joking about it here's a
cartoon that just recently appeared now
in january
in one of the fox news
cartoons what is that horrific smell
smells like corruption to me
and then it says here rest in peace
hillary's presidential election chances
it seems that there is a rising from the
grave
so they're speculating about it because
biden is so unpopular
i wonder who would win this time around
whether the people would play the same
game all over again and get all excited
and
not realize that they're playing a game
of regellian dialect you know what to be
observers
you don't get emotionally involved in
this no you don't have to and then you
actually if you're not emotionally
involved you actually can
try and see what the biblical
perspective on all of this is okay so
even if this happens doesn't matter if
it doesn't happen but if it does happen
the game plan will remain unchanged
we're moving towards the kings of the
world giving their power unto the beast
and once they are so involved that they
cannot
make a retreat anymore there's only one
thing for them to do and that is to step
forward give that power unto the beast
and then the end will come yeah
now martin we also spoke about
depopulation
it wasn't a very popular topic
and we
were called conspiracy theorists
at least we called the episode
conspiracy theorists ah excellent i'm
glad we did that
but what's interesting is that some of
the web pages we quoted
seemed to have disappeared
in the meantime that portion def yeah
yes but other people have taken it up
and have been speaking about it
and uh it's very interesting what's
happening in the world at the moment
and the future will tell
in any case we never said anything we
just quote it right correct so nobody
can accuse us of conspiracies we just
quote it
all right so martin let's look at what
we said at that stage
uh this comes directly from their own
webpage and they are going to explain
here why they have this massive
prediction of a population reduction
we'll look at that at it in a moment
so sorry to disappoint many of you with
our forecast it is getting worse and
worse every year since the beginning of
the pre-crisis in 2007
and they're not going to say anything
else about it
now yeah here is a very interesting
sentence it says the figure itself is
not important what is relevant is the
fact that the scenario can evolve beyond
the initial conditions
from a 50 percent death toll to more
than 90 percent
that's interesting wiping out 90
by the way no pandemic or nuclear war is
included in the forecast
they're talking about a pandemic here
but in this forecast in this case
no pandemic
or nuclear war is in the forecast
so what will wipe out those populations
i don't know
now this is where it gets interesting
this is where we have to put on our
thinking camps
south africa just for interest sake
55 million the population will drop to
46 million so
it's a 9 million
drop in population
which is substantial i mean if we had to
say in the next uh
five years
10 million people are going to die
that's quite shocking and that must also
then include births and deaths so
with all of that it still goes down 9
million but when you say to germany 50
million of your population are going to
die
out of your 80 something million
that is
that's shocking beyond measure
now let's look at the poor united states
of america
population 327 million in 2017
they predict it's going to drop to 100
million
now that's
that's so what's going to happen to 227
million people
migrating two-thirds of the population
gone are they all going to move to
mexico
i don't know this is what that makes no
sense
what they're trying to tell you but are
they going to move to canada
no because canada is also it's also got
a drone so
they're definitely not moving anywhere
all right
and it's not a pandemic and it's not a
wall according to them
now martin that debate is still open
right
and we're not at 2025 so we cannot say
whether that prediction will come true
but there are certainly a number of
indications that all is not well
in the state of denmark
as the saying goes
so what can we expect in the next few
years
and
what will the scenario be
and what will the state of the world be
before the coming of christ
well according to the bible
not a nice place when the son of man
comes will he find faith
that's the first question
if he didn't come
no flesh would survive
says the bible
and for that reason the time will be cut
short right
so martin
i
still stand by everything that we said
in the last hundred
episodes now we dealt only with the mild
issues
and as we can see those mild issues are
not even so mild
they already touch on
they they're touching on pretty serious
issues like the destruction of a great
portion of humanity
now how this will all unfold we will see
as we progress through the year 2022.
now in our next episode
we will be touching on some of the other
issues also a recap
of we will continue with a recap and see
what we said and where we are now
but unfortunately many of the things
that we predicted and many of the things
that are
are no longer acceptable on certain
medias yeah so i think we will have to
switch to another
media platform yes another media
platform in order to bring this
information yeah so the viewers must
already know the next one
will not be on this platform no
so
that was a hundred episodes in review
and we've just
touched on a few i mean this is
episode 24
and
there are still
three quarters of the episodes ahead now
we won't go through everything we'll
just do two of those and then we'll
continue
with this other important topic
what does this mean for our spiritual
life we have to start concentrating
on these issues
so may the god of heaven give us wisdom
as we approach another very bumpy year
we do not know what it brings but we
know what prophecy says
and we have seen in this episode
that the downward spiral
that humanity has chosen to embrace
is likely to continue
that's important what you've just said
i just want to reiterate
when jesus comes and he destroys the
wicked
it will be their own choice it will be
by their own choice
and many many a soul is crying out how
long sovereign lord how long
let's pray
heavenly father we are not living in a
rosy world
and many many people are in despair
lord you know how many letters we
receive
how many people are totally despaired
and lord it's not
possible it's not possible to apply the
bomb to every need
so we have to appeal to a higher hand in
order to do this
but lord if we can get the information
to the people as to what choices they
need to make in order to stand in that
great day
then it would be a wonderful step
forward
so i pray lord that you will not use
only this ministry but use also the
viewers and anybody else who you can
to spread the word so that people may be
prepared for that great day and stand
who will be able to stand
that is the question that the bible
poses
and that is a question that we need to
answer
grant us wisdom to this end in jesus
name amen
[Music]
you